I mean look why not they shouldn't I'll
I'll be honest going after Donald Trump
was wrong yeah writing him over this is
his total BS yeah but if this is the
standard that that the Democrats and the
FBI want to play by then uh we expect
Joe Biden to get right I mean this is
this from when he was vice president
so that calls into question eligibility
if they want to play this game that it's
illegal to take classified documents
like they did for Trump and they wanted
to argue that it disqualified him for
running again remember this right
they're putting out those memes where
they were like Trump can't run for
president now that he's been uh caught
with these documents oh this is an
interesting thing about Joe Biden there
you're saying huh yeah but that always
kind of happens I mean if they didn't do
anything for Hillary Clinton's private
email server they're not going to do
anything here I mean it's pretty clear
it's pretty obvious I mean what else do
you expect the FBI to do yeah it should
be obviously anybody with a brain that
they treat conservatives Republicans
totally different than what they do to
liberals so obvious double standard
nobody wants to point it out especially
on the left